members here today will be aware of the
shocking revelations from Sky News last
week that parents are being forced to
steal baby formula to feed their infant
children with other parents revealing
that they are watering down formula or
mixing it with other ingredients such as
flour in a desperate attempt to make it
last longer
one of the parents in this situation who
was quoted in Sky's report talked about
his baby's hungry scream
and how he's heard it so often that he
knows it now
it's also being reported that an
unregulated Black Market has sprung up
of second-hand baby formula often less
safe than formula found in supermarkets
being sold online at a cheaper price
that parents are now turning to in their
panic
the British pregnancy advisory service
has warned parents being forced to make
these decisions is putting the UK on the
brink of a Public Health crisis
let me be clear from the start the fact
parents are in this situation in 21st
century Britain is utterly shameful